All right.
Listening to
President Biden
there, speaking from the Oval Office,
his first address from the Oval Office
as president,
touting the passage of that bipartisan
bill to raise the debt
ceiling interestingly
calling out Speaker
McCarthy by name,
crediting him with operating in
good faith,
saying that the Republican negotiators
kept their word.
Plenty of compliments
for those Republicans.
Also mentioning Mitch McConnell.
He did.
Interestingly in all of this,
though, make sure to tout something
Democrats really wanted
and that really had cause
many Republicans
who opposed this to go ahead
with that opposition with their vote.
And that was to tout
some of the additional
funding for the IRS.
So our panel is back with me now.
Phil Mattingly, just to ask you.
Your sense
when you heard that obviously,
you know,
he was talking about
how we protected
Social Security
and Medicare,
those important things for seniors.
But he did make a point
of both
complimenting the Republicans,
which is a double edged sword and
touting the IRS.
Yeah, Erin,
you know,
I was just exchanging text back
and forth
with a Republican member of Congress
who said there was nothing new in here.
And my response was exactly.
And while that might seem
a little bit
strange,
given the fact it's an Oval Office
address, given the fact it's a Friday,
this has been the president's
theory of the case for years.
It was what his theory
the case was during the campaign.
And I think you listen
to this speech understanding
where his priorities were.
What he has long been focused on,
and I think to
some degree,
what his message is and will be over
the course of the next 15, 16 months.
Yes. Compromise is important.
Bring down the temperature is important.
Being willing to negotiate
is important on policy
in order to govern, not on principles.
And by that
I mean his focus on the fact Medicare
and Social Security were kept out.
To your point
about the legislative priorities
and the legislative wins that he had
in those
first two years, ensuring
that those
were largely left untouched
except for the shifting
of some of that IRS funding.
But making very clear
that the willingness and ability
to talk to Republicans
and get bipartisan agreement
was important to know
there wasn't any dramatic new development
or announcement
or policy in these remarks.
This was a framing speech,
a last word speech
And I think very much a
this is the president's
theory of the case speech,
whether you think it's new or not.
Right. Right.
Well, in theory of the case
is, of course,
what he's doing as he's
now right up for reelection, right
this is a campaign we know.
How do you think it goes over
with Speaker McCarthy,
with Senator McConnell,
when the president had states
calls them out
to compliment them,
to say
they operated
in good faith,
to say that they kept their word?
Do those things
are those things good for them?
Are those things just just unfortunately,
in the world that we live in now
just bad?
Erin, they are what they are
because it's no change
to who
Biden has been all along
from the time that he took office to now
He hasn't changed his tone at all
when he talks about Republicans.
He starts out by thanking them,
complimenting them.
So to your point
about this being a campaign now,
I haven't seen Biden
take on campaign mode
compared to his predecessor, Trump,
who would sort of
speak about
whatever the substance of the day
was, policy in a way that was moody
Trump would,
you know, take a different tone
every time.
Biden, what you see is what you get.
And there was a lot to bite off tonight
in tonight's remarks.
He really ran the gamut
talking from the deficit
cutting spending.
Of course, complimenting
those Republicans, as you said.
But a couple things I liked.
I like that
he used that line
I said, no,
I think that was pretty strong.
He wanted to show that he's still here,
he's still in command,
and he's able to do the job cognitively.
That's really big.
But the other part that I didn't love
because I don't think this
is going to have an impact
when we go to the grocery store shelves,
what do we see or what do we see?
He talked about inflation
slowing for the 10th
for the 10th straight month.
Yeah.
I don't feel that in everyday life.
Republicans certainly don't.
So for
whatever this was
him taking a victory lap
and certainly this was historic.
This was still an 11th hour
governing situation.
So I see Biden as having maintain
the status quo
and not really
have brought the claws out tonight.
What do you think, Jeff Zeleny? Was this?
Was this a taste of a
Biden campaign speech or not?
Without question.
I mean, and
he shouldn't be faulted for that.
I mean, this is a president
reasserting his authority
from the Oval Office
to the American people
about what he has done
and what his ideas are to go forward.
This is what presidents do.
I think that it was as much of a
theory of the case for his campaign,
for his reelection
than anything we have heard.
We have largely seen a campaign video.
We've seen him to a couple addresses.
But I think this laid out
in very stark terms
his view, his theory of the case, Erin.
The question
is, are Americans still listening
to President Biden?
The question is, are independents
or even some of the Democrats
who supported him
still listening to the president
and to get the president's approval
rating up from historic lows?
The White House knows
that they must win over
some of the
very people who supported him,
some of the very people
who generally have good feelings for him,
but are ready to sort of move
to something else.
So I think this was the beginning
of reasserting his command,
reasserting his
you know,
his control over Washington,
showing, look,
I did work with both sides.
This is why you sent me to Washington
to get here in the most important part.
Are people still listening to Joe Biden?
And of course,
that's going to be the crucial question.
Van.
I'll also say, you know,
when you when you hear this,
I understand you operate in the moment.
The politics are about the moment
they're about, I protected you.
They're not about big picture.
But, Van, honestly,
some of this is frustrating, right? Okay.
Social Security's protected.
Social Security
benefits are going to be cut by 25%.
People are going to get less
than 80%, maybe 75% of what
they think
they're going to get in just a few years.
Right.
Because something has to be done on
Social Security.
So I get it. You seize the moment.
I did nothing.
Now it doesn't take away
the fact
that there are very huge decisions
that this country needs to make,
that the political system right
now, frankly, completely
fails us at doing
I think you are correct.
That's just the question is
do you want to use a debt,
a debt
ceiling, hostage debate situation
to resolve that stuff?
I agree.
There's you got to have stuff to do
and you got to move stuff for it.
I just want to say, you know,
Joe Biden just keeps being Joe Biden.
He just does the same Joe Biden thing
and he keeps winning.
And it's just it is kind of strange
because he says, yeah, I like everybody.
We can all get along and Americans
can always do great things.
And you guys have a good night.
And, you know, he's
it seems kind of corny,
but then you look at the record
of all the bills
that he's passed and the stuff
he's done on climate stuff
he's done on infrastructure stuff
he's done the CHIPS Act,
you know, this debt ceiling thing behind.
So there's just it's
I think for those of us
who expect something new
or dramatic or exciting,
or interesting or different, he's
just like that old slugger.
He just goes up there
every time he hits a triple
and then goes back to the dugout, hits
another triple goal.
And you look at the scoreboard
and he is doing pretty well.
That said,
there are big problems
that are still not being addressed.
If they ever do get addressed, it will be
I think it looks like
in the mode of a Joe Biden
where you do
at the end of the day
with after
after all the nonsense,
you get to a bipartisan consensus,
you get a big vote,
everybody gets a little bit of love.
Everybody gets go home with a cookie
and a pat on the head from grandpa.
We do it all again next week.
And you know, Michael, to you,
to your point
about an Oval Office address,
maybe the reason he doesn't
hasn't given one until tonight is
it's not the best format for him.
Let's just be honest, right?
He's better
when he's interacting with people.
But he had
you know, he delivered a speech
and he had, you know, the moment sort
of where he seemed to be
the most animated
you know, talking about his father.
Right.
His father saying,
don't you tell me what you value.
Show me your budget
and I'll tell you what you value.
There were moments where he was
you know,
as if there were people with him.
Did he did he deliver in that regard,
Michael, what he needs to
or as everyone saying here,
does it just not matter?
Because people know you get what you
get is a known quantity
it was a fine set of remarks in my notes.
I wrote a preview of coming attractions
because now
I have a slightly different take
on the Republican side of the aisle.
This campaign has gone from zero to 100
in like no time.
And I sense that he's
champing at the bit to be heard
and that this is the way
in which he's going to campaign
much like he stayed in Delaware.
And I don't say that as a pejorative.
We were in the midst of the pandemic,
but I think it's going to be
an Oval Office Rose Garden strategy.
And this is the way
you're going to see him
try to respond to that,
which is said about him
by his Republican opponents
for the next several months.